la socialisation est le processus par
lequel les individus intériorisent les
normes les règles les valeurs les
comportements les rôles les attitudes
qui sont attendues de sa part dans la
collectivité dans laquelle il évolue la
socialisation commence dès notre enfant
dès la naissance et ce poursuit tout au
long de la vie la socialisation est un
mécanisme diffus dont nous n'avons pas
forcément conscience en effet on ne nous
annonce pas que nous allons être
socialisés cela se fait dans la vie
courante sépare des encouragements par
des renforcements positifs mais aussi
des sanctions négatives que la
socialisation peut être efficace en
effet si nous commettons un impair si
nous ne respectons pas les règles ou les
normes du groupe dans lequel nous sommes
nous risquons démocrits des réprimantes
et d'autres formes de sanction je vous
donne rendez-vous sur la société si vous
souhaitez découvrir d'autres concepts de
base des sciences sociales